sorry okay there you go all right now i
can start
as chair of the fish and game and marine
resources committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the order i
am confirming that we are
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to com
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the
following website address
https www.zoom.us
backslash j backslash 9305-8607-283
or dialing one of the following phone
numbers one
three one two six two six six
seven nine nine or one
nine two nine two oh five six
zero nine nine providing public notice
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meetings
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access
if anybody has a problem please call
271-3600
or email at hcs at
ledge dot state dot nh
dot u s adjourning the meeting if the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
assisting us joel anderson
is the meeting host additional staff
providing support are pam smarling
and brad greenland this is a work
session on bills referred to the
committee for interim study
an executive session will follow copies
of the interim study bills have been
posted on the main page of the general
court website under the hearing
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required by
the right to know law
um representative dottonville
you have to un unmute yourself
here and no one is with me
thank you representative eisner
representative craig
i'm present uh no one is in the room but
uh my wife and son are at home and it is
an open
uh floor plan so anyone may wander
through at any moment
thank you representative bosman
i'm here and uh no one is with me
representative la flame present and
all alone representative rubric
i am here and i'm by myself
representative egan
oh sorry i had my phone on you i'm here
and sugar hill and
by myself representative king
i'm here and i'm by myself
representative howard
i'm in my kitchen and i'm surrounded by
covered spirits
representative love
i'm here alone and
i'm representative harvey i'm in my
office and
um i'm alone but my husband is in the
house
um with that i'd like to open the um
session on hb 1585
i would like to remind everybody that
this is
um a bill for interim study
so this is not necessarily a hearing um
we've already had a hearing on it
but um we will discuss the bill and then
um go into an executive session our
two options are
no further legislation is necessary at
this time
or um
don't correct me the right i recommend
it for
future legislation thank you i was
stumbling over the right words
thank you recommended for future
legislation
so um with that hb 1585
i believe was um representative egan's
bill
it's been a while so just kind of
refresh our minds about the bill
um and um and then i'll open it for
discussion
and emotion and discussion
right um the bill was to increase
the fines on
poaching and
littering on behalf of
benefit funding for
the commission for the uh fishing game
commission
simplify it
and can i have a motion concerning house
bill 1585
i moved to uh that bill
uh ought to pass
no we just have two options no further
legislation it's necessary
yeah i i withdraw my motion
okay so can i have a
motion please can i can i move
yes i didn't know if i was allowed to
move my own bill
um oh yes i move i move that the bill
seeks further legislation
a second right just for clarification be
recommended for future legislation
all right yeah i move that they'll be
with that recommendation does that mean
that it's being recommended for future
legislation
during this term
it would be for the for the the next
term
so no somebody would have to file a file
in
lsr for the next session
okay all right so and any discussion on
that
pardon me
who was the second please
representative donald trump it was
cottonville
representative dottonville seconded
i do have madam chair two brief updates
thank you so knowing that
um unfortunately covett had sort of
stopped any of the discussions that we
had talked about
post um the hearing of connecting with
different organizations that could
participate
in looking at how to better
assess finding um over the summer
over the year summer i did have an
opportunity
to reach out to two local
fish and game lieutenants one that lives
in brentonia in my district
and is the the coordinator for
district two and then the coordinator
for
my region district three um and i talked
with both of them
from sort of an on the ground point of
view that they felt that this was
worthwhile um and they both said the
same thing which was
you know have you reached out to colonel
jordan and they said
that was the ultimate goal if cova
didn't exist that we would have had a
meeting
with colonel jordan and and paul
sanderson
to talk about how the state agency
could give us insight into
moving these five increases along
so that's one bit of anecdotal evidence
is that the
sort of the on the ground fish and game
wardens felt that this was
worthy um the second one was i did have
a brief conversation
and a variety of topics with the new
head of society for protection of new
hampshire for us jack savage
and told him of this bill and he said
he thought that spinif would support
anything that helps
fish and game better manage and protect
our
wildlife and our our natural
surroundings
so it did a little work but we couldn't
do much else
thank you anyone else
i'm checking hands here
i also had a meeting with the new
director
for fish and game as well as
commissioner eric stoll
and paul sanderson on a totally
different matter but
this bill came up and they are also
looking forward to
working with representative egan on
future legislation so that
it can the mechanism for
um for managing this bill
could be worked on in a better way
to actually be of an advantage to new
hampshire fish and game
so i do see a hand
oh she's taking it down okay
so i think what i'm any any other
discussion on
hb 1585.
so i think what i'm going to do so that
we don't have to go from hearing to
executive session i think i'm going to
close the hearing on
1585 open the hearing on hb 1433
then we'll do an executive session for
both of those bills at at the end of
this hearing so um representative
shewett i see is
in the attendees and so i would ask
representative stewart if you wanted to
just give us a brief
um
review of the bill since it was your
bill
representative stewart
thank you very much chair uh yes it was
my bill
um and i
i'm still thinking that
we should try and do something on this
um
it deals with the idea was to deal with
the population of ticks
in the state um and i had
talked to different people from
different state agencies
that would be concerned with this
this bill had a different thrust than
most of the bills dealing with ticks
most of them had to do with dealing with
the diseases
that ticks cause my idea was to try and
control the proliferation
of ticks as a preventative measure
and i had spoken with the various people
named
in the bill to serve on the commission
to try and come up with ways that we
could
control the population of ticks
and still not adversely affect
pollinators for example bees and so
forth
other insects that are useful
um i do recall i believe it was at your
executive session that representative
eisner i think had
a large report that had been put out by
health and human services and i didn't
get the chance to ask because you were
executing
but i was curious it seemed to me that
from what i learned about that report it
dealt most
mostly with treatment of diseases
and the effects of the diseases that
ticks
cause and i don't know if she recalls
that report if that's the case
or if it did actually deal with methods
to control the tick
population
may i respond what oh
um representative schuett yes
this lengthy report not only addresses
the diseases
but it also recommends methods of trying
to control the diseases
um there's page 22 and 23.
there's uh like seven um areas
that they recommend uh avoid
i don't want to read them all uh just
for the sake of time
but it goes into tick zones wood chip
areas wood pile
take migration jones takes safe stone
gardens playsets
um then it even goes into eliminating
hosts and hose habit can reduce the
number of ticks encountered
mice other rodents can invade homes
uh then it goes physical environment
control municipal and city planning so
it also has recommendations
for towns and cities so
um it does address the
uh you know tick infestation especially
with deer
so it is a very detailed report it's
available
online that's where i uh encoding from
in addition there in our local newspaper
on august 27th
oh i don't know if you can see this i
don't you're putting me on
but anyways there's a headline
prevention guidelines for mosquito
and dick diseases so
there's a lot of public information
already available
and this newspaper article it also
for more information on mosquito borne
and diseases
visit the dhs website so there is a
website of
available at all times for the public to
um get more educated on um
what to do when if they're concerned
about ticks and mosquitoes
and that's all i have thank you
any other questions or discussions if
if i can just say um thank you very much
representative eiser i appreciate that
i leave it to the committee if they feel
that
anything further should be done in this
area or not
thank you okay thank you representative
should
appreciate it um any other discussion
uh i'm gonna just check hands make sure
that i have i'm not
missing anybody oh um representative
howard
yes thank you madam chair i just like to
say
i ride around and i see a lot of you
guys
that say yeah they've been treated for
tick and mosquitoes
so there are companies out there already
doing this kind of work
okay thank you
i'm not seeing any other hands
okay all right so um um
i think we can move into executive
session for both of these bills
i'm going to close this hearing move
into executive session
let's start with uh the one we just
we're talking about hb
1433 i need a motion please
my recommendation is no future
legislation is needed at this time
is there a second second
all right so the vote is going to be a
roll call vote
i'm going to um um
just go across my screen um starting
with representative johnville
i i've uh are we voting on both or or
just
just one at a time so hb 1433 the motion
is no further legislation
is necessary i vote yay
representative eisner yay
representative craig yes
representative bosman yes
representative leflane
yes representative egan
yes rubricht
no um
representative king
representative king yes
representative howard yes
representative love yes
the chair votes yes did i miss anybody
hey representative king would you please
read the vote
there would be 10 years one night
no further legislation is necessary i'm
going to close the executive session on
hp 1433 and go back to
an executive session on hb 1585
the re the motion was
future legislation would be necessary
any other last minute discussion before
i call the role
okay oh representative dottenville
you're muted were you saying something
no okay uh representative dottonville
uh yes representative eisner
yes representative craig
yes representative bosman
yes represent harvey uh pardon me i
i didn't know if we had a motion we did
yes and a second
did we have a motion in a second yes the
motion blade
i'm sorry yes the motion was that future
legislation
would be
necessary okay i was just worried i
didn't hear there was a second to that
and there was representative dottonville
okay okay all right
um okay so i forget where i was
representative leflame
yes representative egan
yes representative rubricht yes
um representative king
yes representative howard
yes representative love yes
and the chair votes yes representative
king
when you're ready would you believe
please read off the the vote
that was 11 years unanimous
thank you and so representative egan
um i assume that this is something that
you're going to work on
it would be my honor okay and so you
know
you're free to form some sort of an ad
hoc committee
and um if you want some help either from
this committee or from anybody
to help you work on on uh future
legislation
so just wanted to let you know that you
could do that
or so based on the committee
the bill that goes i have to refile
that is what your goal is that what has
to happen next yes that's right that's
right
a new bill has to be filed right right
but
but that box in between now and that is
what you're saying madam chair
yes um and you'll refile a completely
new bill i i don't think you'll file the
old bill with amendments or something
you'll refile
a whole new bill and you can um
it doesn't have to be there is a
september filing period
which might even be open now but um
it's been advised to just wait until the
november filing period so
um you have a couple months to to think
about it
and i think the november filing period
starts
um right after the general election
november 8th
around in there yeah okay representative
correct thank you
well i guess i just want to say that the
september uh period
ends tomorrow but you can uh
submit the lsr merely as a as a
placeholder
and then work on the legislation in the
november filing period
thank you i i think they though they
will look for some
um information along with that filing as
to um
they do ask for complete information i
don't know if it has to be complete
complete but um so it can't just be a
title
supposedly one other thing um
while i'm speaking um just a reminder
each one of these
uh recommendations for the two bills
each one has to have a statement that
goes with it
um that will be printed in the house
calendar so the the
person who made the motion uh should
write up a
a statement explaining the committee's
rationale for their recommendation
and they should send that to the madam
chairman
um so um
representative egan would you please
write up a little statement about
um the recommendation for your bill
and uh representative eisner if you
could write write up a little
um statement uh for
1433 and where do we forward that to man
of chair
to me okay yeah and i'll i'll get it
today or
24 hours
um joel is there i mean
i think you want it fairly quickly but
it doesn't have to be today does it
no i mean it it the the deadline is
isn't for a while
for committees to report but it would be
a good idea to do as
soon as possible or you know a
reasonable length of time so
right but but don't stress out about it
this afternoon
it's a beautiful day go outside do it
tomorrow morning
[Laughter]
any other questions
i think that pretty much concludes the
business for fish and game
for our session i do thank everybody for
uh your work we are um we do
appreciate everybody's input um and and
the hard work that you've done
we would like to express sadness that
mark
uh won't be joining us next year and we
will
miss right
i think um when i asked mark to be
our clerk he very graciously said yes
not realizing what a
terrible job it is to be clerk it's it's
the hardest
job if you ever have a chance to fill in
for clerk it's it's just
a very very difficult job and mark has
done a wonderful job
at it not only during the meetings but
just to make sure that everything was
right for
um heather goalie oftentimes he would
come back
into concord the the following day just
to make
sure that everything was um uh clear
and and filed properly and so forth so
every one of our meetings
he had two meetings so we
we we definitely appreciate your um
your willingness to do the work yeah i
actually
i won my primary
you i did not record it correctly i i
got calls from people all over the us
that
are friends of mine saying oh sorry
about you losing like
i didn't lose it's the newswire
thank you for the the kind words well
yeah
i well i'm i'm sorry that i um
assumed that you had lost because i did
get read it through the news
i'm not sorry about any of the words
that i said about you though because
those were all true so
you've done a great job and that's
wonderful we'll look forward to having
you back then so
all right any other business right
there's very little
easy ron madam chair i'm very relieved
because having filled in for mark once
or twice i had a feeling that you were
going to try and tap me so now i
i have a retreat but mark i'm still
available for you when you are ill or on
business i'm glad that we fill in
thank you yes it's been a nightmare for
me thinking about oh my gosh who
what sucker can i get to do this
all right can i have a motion for a
journey
oh moved second second
second all in favor aye aye
aye right we'll we'll see you all soon
thank you so much for your work
bye-bye you too okay you need to stand
by catherine
thank you um meeting gober right
yes okay my apologies i had talked to
mark